these meditation apps promise inner
peace relaxation and mindfulness Z
meditations meditation time and
headspace will start with Z meditations
the full version is available for 4
euros 49 cents a plus with its 5 to 40
minute sessions this app makes a very
nice impression find a quiet and
comfortable place where you can sit down
and meditate a - it doesn't have many
options now it's time for meditation
time but only for unconventional
thinkers this is for individual
meditation the user can set the total
length and the intervals a plus the
settings include Gong and ambient sounds
a drawback there are no instructions
your eyes and arrived in your body
finally let's check out headspace the
basic version is free but lifelong
access for 300 euros is a bit costly but
the packages range from basics to health
to sports each package includes several
sessions conducted by a relaxing voice
my name is Andy and over the next 10
days I'm going to show you a really
simple way of getting some more
headspace shift says if you take your
meditation seriously you need headspace
it's suitable for beginners as well as
the more enlightened want to find out
more about the digital world then check
out our Facebook page DW digital you'll
find all the latest news and trends as
well as interesting apps exciting
gadgets and helpful tutorials and of
course all the shift reports are there
too
like us post your comments give us your
opinions at DW digital